BUT FIRST, HONORING BUSH BY
BASHING TRUMP.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
WITH A FORMER PRESIDENT PASSES
AWAY IT'S APPROPRIATE TO
CELEBRATE HIS LIFE, HIS
ACHIEVEMENTS AND TO REMIND THE
PUBLIC OF HIS RECORD AND HIS
LEGACY.
SADLY, THOUGH, WITH THE DEATH OF
GEORGE H.W. BUSH SOME IN THE
MEDIA AND POLITICIANS FROM BOTH
PARTIES ARE ABUSING THIS MOMENT
TO TRASH, INSTEAD, THE SITTING
PRESIDENT.
AS THE BUSH MOTORCADE WAS MAKING
ITS WAY TO THE CAPITOL FOR THE
LAST TIME MSNBC'S NICOLE
WALLACE, A FORMER BUSH AIDE
HERSELF COULD NOT RESTRAIN
HERSELF.
>> I THINK WHAT EVERYONE IS
GETTING AT IS UNDER DONALD TRUMP
THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENCY HAS
BEEN DEBASED IN A WAY THAT'S
UNIMAGINABLE FOR PEOPLE WOSERVED
EVERY PAST PRESIDENT.
I THINK WHAT'S LOST IN THIS
MOMENT IS OUR REVERENCE AND THE
WAY WE NEED THE TRADITIONS OF
THE PRESIDENCY.
>> Laura: SHE'S TRASHING THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT AS THE
MOTORCADE IS INCHING ITS WAY UP
CAPITOL HILL.
THEN THERE WAS THIS GEM FROM
EARLIER IN THE DAY.
>> LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS AT
WEDNESDAY'S MEMORIAL SERVICE.
MY PREDICTION IS THAT TRUMP
FAKES MORE RESPECT FOR A FAMILY
WHOSE UNPRECEDENTED HISTORY OF
PUBLIC SERVICE HAS REPEATEDLY
BELITTLED, THEN HE GOES BACK TO
MAKING A MOCKERBY OF THE VERY
OFFICE PRESIDENT BUSH AND THIS
NATION LONG REVERED.
>> Laura: PRESIDENT BUSH WAS A
MAN WHO LOVED HIS COUNTRY, LOVED
HIS FAMILY, HIS FAITH AND HIS
FRIENDS.
HE WAS A WAR HERO AND A
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANT
THROUGHOUT MOST OF HIS LIFE.
SO ARE THESE FOLKS REALLY
HONORING THAT LEGACY AND HIS
INNATE SENSE OF DECENCY AND
KINDNESS BY SLASHING THE MAN WHO
ENTERED THE WHITE HOUSE 25 YEARS
AFTER HIM?
LOOK, EVEN IF YOU DON'T CARE FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP, EVEN IF YOU
JUST HATE PRESIDENT TRUMP,
TRYING SHOWING JUST A LITTLE BIT
OF CLASS AND DECORUM, AS BUSH 41
WOULD HAVE.
THE HITS ON TRUMP -- SUBTLE AND
NOT SUBTLE AT ALL -- HAVE BEEN
INTERWOVEN THROUGHOUT THE
COMMENTARY AND THE COVERAGE.
>> THEY BOTH BELIEVE THAT THE
PRESIDENCY IS BIGGER THAN
THEMSELVES WHICH IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT THIS PRESIDENT
ALWAYS ADHERES TO.
>> WHAT GEORGE HERBERT WALKER
BUSH IS BEING REMEMBERED FOR
THIS WEEK ISN'T A TWEET OR ISN'T
A PRESS RELEASE OR NOTHING MUCH
MORE THAN HIS FUNDAMENTAL
CHARACTER.
>> I DO NOT KNOW HOW IT'S GOING
TO WORK WHEN DONALD TRUMP IS AN
EX-PRESIDENT AND THEORETICALLY A
MEMBER OF THIS CLUB.
I REALLY THINK IT'S GOING TO
CHANGE BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
THESE MEN WHO SHARE SOMETHING IN
COMMON WILL SHARE THAT IN COMMON
WITH DONALD TRUMP.
>> Laura: AT SOME POINT YOU
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT TO SAY TO
THESE PEOPLE.
THAT WAS RON CLAIN, BY THE WAY.
THEY REDUCE A PRESIDENTIAL DEATH
TO JUST A POLITICAL BATTERING
RAM LIKE ANY OTHER ISSUE.
BUT WHAT YOU HEAR -- IF YOU
LISTEN CLOSELY, IS THE LAST GASP
OF AN EMBITTERED ESTABLISHMENT.
AS WE HAVE SEEN ACROSS EUROPE
AND ACROSS MUCH OF THE UNITED
STATES, POPULISM IS SWAMPING THE
OLD GUARD, WHETHER IT'S ON THE
RIGHT OR ON THE LEFT, SO RATHER
THAN DIRECT THEIR ANGER AT
TRUMP, THE ESTABLISHMENT FRANKLY
IN BOTH PARTIES SHOULD BE
DIRECTING IT AT THEMSELVES, FOR
IT IS THEIR POLICIES THAT THE
VOTERS TURNED AGAINST IN 2016.
THINGS LIKE OPEN BORD EFRZ,
CHINA TRADE, NAFTA, HIGH TAXES,
ENDLESS WARS, THOSE WEREN'T
TRUMP POLICIES, THEY WERE THE
POLICIES OF THE ESTABLISHMENT
AND THE ESTABLISHMENT G. O.
P.'ERS THINK THE WAY TO WIN THEM
BACK IS TO BELITTLE PRESIDENT
TRUMP EVEN DURING FORMAL ON-AIR
EULOGIES AND TRIBUTES?
AT A TIME LIKE THIS WHEN A
FATHER, A GRANDFATHER, A GREAT
GRANDFATHER AND A FORMER
PRESIDENT HAS DIED, WE SHOULD BE
BIGGER THAN THE PETTY POLITICS
OF THE MOMENT.
I THINK WE SHOULD BE CAPABLE OF
UNITING AS AMERICANS AND
CELEBRATING THE BEST OF GEORGE
H.W. BUSH WITHOUT RESORTING TO
THE SAME OLD USUAL POLITICAL